how are you guys we have a close of 17
on the pilot okay we're in a program
when you smart get to it okay we're
gonna add a key okay because it's not
our case laughing so make sure that the
vehicle is on okay
so we're gonna go to Honda green now
we're gonna go to smart key now type
tool would be for a tacky all right type
three would be four out he's lost okay
so we're gonna go to type tool now we're
gonna go to add a smart key double-click
the but the start button weather
ignition can be switched on yes I can
okay so take all the smart keys out of
the car okay so we're taking all of
Smarties out of the car so we're gonna
play the smart keys right underneath the
car okay so then we're gonna press yes
put one programs mark in the car so
we're gonna get the program smart key
inside the car which is this one okay
we're gonna put it right there little
press okay
takes more care of the car okay so we're
gonna take it out of the car okay then
we're gonna press okay put a noose mark
in the car okay so we're going to put
the new smart key inside the car
smooth smart key you guys so we're gonna
press okay
switch the ignition off within 15
seconds Commission off switch ignition
on press it twice remember you guys okay
mission is on and I'll switch it off
again press it once okay Fitz ignition
on twice okay
weather Sakura indicator is extinguished
I don't see any security light you guys
okay Georgianna press yes switch
ignition off okay so ignition on within
15 seconds so 1 2 switch ignition off
press on once
switch ignition on again so twice two on
once okay
program success okay so let's try a
smart key see if it works okay
so it works perfect okay let's so let's
try it out
what's perfect there are more programmed
with the with the smart key portion okay
so you worry about that step on the
break
perfect so thank you guys for watching
if you guys like this video and it
helped you guys out make sure you hit
like and subscribe to my channel for
more videos if you have any questions or
concerns leave a comment below okay till
next time you guys